بعد اقل من عام يزدل الستار اخيرا على
القضيه التي هزت الراي العام في مصر
السلطات المصريه تعلن تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
ضد محمد اشرف الذي قتل زميلته نيره اشرف
في هذا المكان امام جامعه المنصوره
الجريمه تعود تفاصيلها لقتل المتهم للمجني
عليها بعد رفضها الارتباط به النيابه
احاله المتهم الى محكمه الجنايات وبعد اقل
من اسبوع تقررت احاله اوراق القضيه الى
المفتي وبعد صدور حكم الاعدام رفضت محكمه
النقض قبول الطعم اسره المتهم تسلمت
جثمانه من مستشفى المنصوره الدولي مصادر
صحفيه اشارت الى دخوله في حاله هستيريه
قبل الاعدام محامي اسره نيره يرى ان سرعه
تنفيذ حكم الاعدام تعد رساله من الدوله ضد
نوع جديد من الجرائم التي اثارت الخوف
داخل المجتمع كان لازم الدوله بيدي من
حديد تقول له استنوا وحاسبهم يا شباب ده
في دوله في قانون في قضاء مصري يقدر ان هو
يجزم ويحزم الامور دي كلها ويحازم الجريمه
في البلد والد نيره رحب بتنفيذ حكم
الاعدام واكدا انه شعر اخيرا بالعدل
والقصاص بعدما تعرضت له دييره من ظلم على
يد قاتلها وايضا من حملات التشهير التي
طالتها بعد وفاتها ومش القصاص الكامل لسه
هو القصاص من محمد علي لكن لسه بقيه الناس
اللي خاضوا في سيرتها وفي سمعتها وبشرفها
بس انا كان في نفسي النهارده الحق يبقى
كامل بان يتذاع جزء من تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
زي ما هي كل الناس شافتها في الحادثه
والعالم كله شافها كان في نفسي برده انه
ده يتشاف وهو مش وهو حتى بيتعدم هو داخل
على غرفه الاعدام ده اللي كان كنت بتمناه
اهالي المنصوره عبروا عن ساعدتهم بتنفيذ
الحكم ولكن بقي الانقسامه حول كونه رابعا
لعدم اقدام الشباب على تكرار هذه النوعيه
من الجرائم
الوقت تبعتها يعني كان كل البنات ماشيه
بقى ما بتنزلش وكده لا مش قوي لان هي
القررت بعد كده كتير مش مره واحده بس قررت
بعد كده كتير ورغم وهم قالوا قبل كده انهم
هياخدوا حكم الاعدام بعضها القرار برده ما
حدش سكت ستبقى صورته نيره اشرف المرسومه
على جدران جامعه المنصوره حيث قتلت
كاتسكار دائما لجريمه بشعه هزت المجتمع
فيما يظل التحدي الحقيقي في ضروره معالجه
الاسباب النفسيه والاجتماعيه وراء انتشار
هذا النوع من الجرائم احمد عثمان العربيه
مدينه المنصوره محافظه الدقهليه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات